anything when it comes to retirement
there's something called the three
legged stool maybe try to pull this up
maybe three-legged stools see what comes
up now let's just test houses members
coming in three-legged stool so they
call it the three-legged soul of
retirement
welcome back marcelo they called the
three-legged stool of retirement and
here are the three things that you need
to have number one
is a pension this is a three-legged
still retirement number one is a pension
now here's the deal most people
don't have pensions these days maybe if
you're police officer you work for the
government you're a teacher you have a
pension i would say less than five
percent of the population has a pension
that's number one that's one leg of the
stool did you find this you just hit
images bro just hit images
number two
is social security
number two is social security and the
anyone want to guess how much the
average person
gets from social security each month
take a guess
how much a month yeah social security
you're retired to get social security no
clue a grand
grant's close i think at most it's 200
yeah not a bad not a bad guess 1500 2
grand so maybe you're getting 20 grand a
year in social security not a lot of
money okay so that's that's the first
two legs of the stool pension social
security third leg of the stool which i
assume you're pulling up an image just
hit three-legged stool image
is your personal
savings that's everything we're talking
about here here we go so back to this
article here we go three-legged still
retirement was i right social security
pension and personal savings see you
know uh you know not just a hat rack up
here
there's actually you know some braces
too know a thing or two something called
a three-legged still retirement so a lot
of people don't have pensions i don't
have a pension do you have a pension no
marcelo they get pinched the comedy
world um no dude not at all no that's
different from
not at all vanessa pension
no no okay pensionless social security
you know do you think social security is
gonna be there for you when you retire
dude i don't i don't know you don't even
know do you think social security's
gonna be there for you and retire
marcelo i don't know where it would come
from it would come from the government
that's where it comes and they just do
it automatically i don't know you pay
into it i haven't i have no idea okay
well maybe maybe next episode we'll talk
about social security a little bit maybe
that's a good idea i have no idea what
that is you have no idea what it is
retirement it's retirement the
government pays you to retire you pay in
when you get a paycheck they take out
taxes obviously and some of that goes to
what's security what's social about that
right that's my question right i'm a
words guy i start to think here i go i
go social security maybe i'm a funny guy
i have a lot of social security when i
get into a social situation i feel
secure i feel like i'm okay i feel like
i'm not gonna ruin the moment i feel
like i'm going to kill it
awesome i do agree with you you have a
lot of social security
i got social skills i guess not we're
not talking about social skills we're
not talking about social media talking
about social security
um
i believe that the social security was
started uh fdr's new deal
this was back after world war ii
um you know so people could retire
comfortably and basically the whole
thing with social security is
they
basically they said after age 65
you maybe it's 62 sorry 62 you can start
receiving social security benefits the
problem was back then you know 80 years
ago life expectancy was age 65. so they
said you'd live for a few years and the
government would give you money for a
few years then you'd die
now
people live to age 80 90 100 no problem
so there's people living on social
security
for 20 30 freaking years you're not and
we talked about how much the average
social security check like a grant you
know 1500 bucks 2 000. you want to live
on 30 years of your life on 20 grand a
year not a good look if you enjoyed that
short clip from the size cast click here
to watch another click here to watch the
full episode or just stay broke
[Music]